drew has had so many memorable roles
during her nearly four decade career
but when we first met her in 1982 she
was seven
sweet and already confident in front of
the camera her first blockbuster e.t
was just about to hit theaters you
excited about e.t coming out this week
of course have you seen the movie yet
yes but i haven't seen it with a live
audience
what was it like working with steven
spielberg it was really fun and i
enjoyed working on e.t you want to do
more movies and keep the family
tradition going yes
[Music]
it's like throwing balloons up and
throwing flowers up
to my lovely teeth i
can't beat anything stephen makes it
special and she makes it special
steven by the way is also drew's
godfather yeah she was born into
hollywood royalty
her parents grandparents and great
grandparents were all actors
but drew was just your typical kid he's
making faces at you right you're not
making it very easy
about you i can't believe the table
running
true barrymore
thank you for this award
i appreciate it very much this is my
first award
e.t became the highest grossing film of
all time
making 663 million dollars at the box
office
its massive success catapulted drew into
the spotlight
at seven years old she became the
youngest person ever
to host snl i'm a berrymart
get me a drink and make it a double
[Applause]
i'm not the little girl from easy
anymore i have grown up
[Applause]
in the 90s drew took on some edgier
roles i can just imagine you know my
godfather watching this
i mean how embarrassing is going to
watch me you know having
sex at a mercedes benz in the rain i
mean that's terrifying
[Music]
i did it for 10 days straight it took to
shoot that scene
[Music]
to do the crying the screaming the
hyperventilation
i was free i cleansed the demons you
know
i was like yes yeah drew faced her share
of demons growing up in the public eye
i think that everybody has problems
growing up growing up is hard to do
but she came out even stronger turning
herself into a rom-com darling
and producing powerhouse i insist you
return my things at once
i didn't want to play cinderella who
waited to be rescued
i couldn't do that you're the wedding
singer i get to come to work every day
and work with adam sandler
and laugh my head off i can just get one
kiss
1999's never been kiss marked two career
milestones for drew
her first executive producer credit and
this one's my 30th so i'm excited about
that
imagine 30. yeah i keep thinking god
i've gotten 30 amazing opportunities
all that we cared about was making this
fun for people
and hopefully enjoying the process
ourselves and then giving it out to
people so that they could have fun
drew barrymore great gardens drew won
her first golden globe in 2010.
you just try your best and then
something like this happen
but her biggest accomplishment was
becoming a mom two years later with the
birth of daughter olive her second
daughter frankie
was born 19 months later they're my
favorite people
on the planet and they are my joy i
understood that when they were born
that that was the purpose of my life